well right now the las vegas housing
market is cooling so what are the
expectations for southern nevada this
fall we connect with the owner of a
local title agency to get the answers
with it slowing down a little bit
i will return to some
normalization kyle wallace is the ceo of
drinks title agency which covers las
vegas and parts of arizona he confirms
that right now sellers in southern
nevada are dropping their prices people
are buying fewer homes we're going to go
through a period of you know sellers
being a little bit disappointed
you know if they hadn't listed their
property you know four or five months
back our unusual last year and a half
had sales prices hitting new all-time
highs buyers flooded with offers and
homes selling rapidly during that time
las vegas saw less than 3 thousand
single family residences available on
any given day but just this week the
availability of homes has almost tripled
as our current inventory has now
exceeded 8 000 with more inventory
available prices are softening the fed
reserve boosting interest rates four
times since march also has an impact
home buyers have to cope with steeper
monthly payments and sellers
experiencing less demand for their homes
27 percent of pending sales in the las
vegas area fell through for the month of
june as interest rates have gone up and
people have seen that change in their
payments you know a lot of people buy
homes based on the payment they have not
necessarily the home value itself as
those payments have changed they've been
more likely to cancel the sharp rise in
rates has cooled the housing market
caused the economy to start slowing but
hasn't done much to lower inflation
looking ahead wallace says keep it all
in perspective by late fall
we've kind of you know become accustomed
to the interest rate
and you know people are going to start
jumping back into the market you know if
you think back
you know five ten years ago
five to six percent interest rates where
we're at right now that was a great
interest rate
you know we were just so used to having
you know in the twos that it there is
some sticker shock
wallace says cash is still king when
buying a home you don't have to worry
about any hiccups with a loan you also
can appeal to the seller by waiving the
appraisal contingency as for the rates
experts don't expect the feds to make
any adjustments until 2024.